Amazon have ordered a brand new TV
series based on the hit game God of War
but what does this mean for Stargate
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so if you haven't already seen it Amazon
have ordered a brand new television show
to be produced God of War which is going
to be a live action adaptation of the
popular game God of War which as all of
our Stargate fans know the main
character Kratos is voiced by
Christopher Judge our very own tilk now
something you may not know is that this
TV series God of War is going to be
created by Mark Fergus and Hawk oxby and
as a regular side tracker you will know
that we have been basically telling you
that Mark Ferguson horcruxby are going
to be creating Stargate but if they're
creating God of War how are they going
to have time now this is something that
we've known about for a really long time
we knew god of war was in pre-production
and Mark Ferguson oxby were going to be
involved in it in some capacity we
didn't report on it on this channel
because it wasn't really relevant to
anything that we normally talk about
now however that Mark Ferguson or Osby
are going to be producing Stargate or at
least they're involved I think it's time
that we talked about the God of War
television show as well now Mark
Ferguson oxby have a production company
this production company is called
penguin in a Parker this is the
production company that is going to be
responsible for bringing Stargate back
to our screens and is also the company
responsible for bringing God of War to
our screens now just like any other
production company think like Sony
Disney Warner Brothers anything like
that they don't always just have one
project on the go now whilst Mark Fergus
and hawksby are the the names associated
with penguin in a bucket there is a
whole production team behind the scenes
as well now something we have to keep in
mind that although Mark Ferguson hook
upsby are at the moment developing a new
TV show there's no guarantee that any
one of them is going to be the
showrunner that could be passed off to
someone else however we do have contacts
in and around MGM and we're told that
Hawk will be leading the god of war
production and Mark himself will be
leading Stargate but as I said this is
all subject to change we don't know
anything for certain just yet as Mark
and Hawk are still in negotiations with
Amazon we don't know for certain who is
going to take the lead with Stargate we
don't know who next Brad Wright is going
to be which leads me on to another point
Brad Wright could still potentially be
involved in Stargate Mark Ferguson Hawk
Mosby are currently developing a new
television show it doesn't mean they're
going to show on it doesn't mean they're
going to be behind the camera in any
capacity they could pass that on to
someone different and potentially that
person could be Brad Wright he could be
involved in some capacity now now this
isn't a rumor this isn't something that
we've heard we don't know for certain
who is going to be involved this is just
hypothetical what could potentially
happen but I personally have had a few
messages on Twitter from people who know
that we talk about Slugger here on this
channel and know that we broke the news
about Mark focus and Hawk oxby doing
Stargate and they messaged me directly
basically saying well these two are
going to be pretty busy how are they
going to get the two done and it all
ties back into the fact that they have a
production company a whole team of
people who are going to be dedicated to
a show in particular whether that's a
team for of war and then a team for
Stargate there were so many variables
when creating a new television show you
have to think of visual effects there's
going to be a whole team based on that
there's going to be a whole writing team
that's going to be directors you're also
going to have producers they might also
bring in people from outside of the
company maybe Brad Wright in this
instance who was going to consult on the
development of the show all of this is
possible and all of this is something
that is going to happen regardless
they're going to build a team of people
dedicated to a specific show who are
going to help develop it whether or not
that involves Brad right we don't know
for sure but it is something that we're
looking closely at and hopefully that is
something that comes into fruition I
mentioned it in the lion last week that
Mark Ferguson Hawk Osby have gone
through a hell of a lot of trouble to
create a Bible to make sure that they're
still within continuity for a new
Stargate series they did that of their
own backs and Amazon loved it Amazon
ultimately chose them to develop the new
show they went for a hell of a lot of
trouble to do that I can't see them
personally I can't see them not drawing
on the expertise of people who have
already developed Stargate Brad Wright
Joseph Pelosi Robert Cooper and I can
also see cast members from the Past
coming back in Amanda Tapping Richard
Dean Anderson Joe Flanagan and even
David Hewlett like I can see all of
those people coming back in some
capacity
so does the announcement of the God of
War TV show mean stuff it's been put on
the back burner absolutely not
absolutely not Stargate is still going
to be pushing forward we are still going
to be getting a TV show it's just all
going to be managing penguin in a park
of the production company who just so
happens to have multiple projects going
on at once thank you so much for
watching if you did enjoy this video
make sure you hit subscribe and press
the Bell notification so you don't miss
a single video whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button down below
there'll be no video from me next week
as I will be taking a break for the
Christmas period but I'll be back just
before the new year so to all of the
side trackers Merry Christmas and have a
fantastic New Year
[Music]